times when I know we'll be together
again as a song that's captivated
generations of jazz singers Thomas qua
stove performed his rendition on jazz
fest bonds opening night the German
bass-baritone has won six echo awards
and four Grammys during the course of
his classical music career in 2012 to
cigarette now he was quitting the stage
since then he's only made rare
appearances at jazz concerts it's mostly
Hayden told not everything I sing as
dictated by notes it's word based
instead on months but sometimes I can
draw notes out or make them rougher I'm
freer and the way I deal with them which
makes things more relaxed many artists
with powerful voices are performing at
this year's Jazz Fest eight of its 22
concerts feature jazz singers Lisa
besosss from Berlin is a veteran on the
jazz scene she's just released her 14th
album
Oh
her songs makes elements of pop jazz
blues and shall song but massage doesn't
like to restrict yourself to any
particular genre and it gets me
ultimately it's about making the music I
love and the music that gives me
pleasure and doing it as distinctively
as possible it's about being
individualistic and doing my own thing
was doing Ovitz affinity
many of the Jazz Fest concerts are
purely instrumental and experimental now
in its seventh year the festival
attempts to present jazz in all its
facets
on 11 evenings route of unknowns are
paired with some of the biggest names in
jazz the idea behind these double
concerts is to introduce audiences to
new artists phineas and Jason Italian
test for me an interesting jazz singer
is a distinctive one someone who's very
special an individual whose music has
character coolest ones at this diversity
is reflected in our lineup come to Daddy
solidified audiences like the idea
attendance is up as pretty musica
festivals musicians festivals are always
the best you get to meet other people
exchange ideas and have fun one after
that festival cameras and I can imagine
that being able to listen to different
acts on a single evening really pulls in
the crowds for people's magnet
overlooked the theme of massages new
album is Laurel Canyon home to many
legendary rock and pop musicians in the
60s and 70s on it she covers hits like
the doors riders on the storm covering
other people's songs has a long
tradition in jazz Thomas claw stove
demonstrated his love for American jazz
and its icons like Frank Sinatra Dean
Martin and Ella Fitzgerald song is
neither song is never the same even if
you sing it a hundred times you always
phrase things a little differently
because in your condition is different
each day your fellow musicians aren't
always in the same message I'm not
always in the same state that keeps
things new and challenging and makes
them so exciting
jazzfest bond runs until May seventh so
music lovers can look forward to many
more beautiful performances